The general experience,
I watched the thing,
the crazy eddie.
Do you remember Crazy Eddie?
When he was getting.
His prices are insane.
Crazy.
Eddie did tell anybody who crazy.
It was crazy.
It was a guy that had stores in all five
boroughs of New York wholesale outlets,
tvs,
stereos,
tvs and everything like that.
I saw.
I was watching them.
SNBC greed.
They have a series called grace given
us.
Let me hear this motherfucker.
Anything and everything and hold letter
came in.
Remember we are not under.
We will not be undersold and we made it
pretty frequently,
but now
he's wearing a Santa Claus outfit.
He's going fucking crazy with fake snow
in the background.
He
like,
like he like hit it out of the park.
Didn't he go to Israel?
He went to high,
but the most brilliant thing he did was
he took it either.
Don't,
don't fucking check fact me on this.
He took it either his nephew,
his son in law,
somebody that he was related to blood,
put them through college so he could get
a job at the irs so they could figure
out how to rob from the irs.
This is how fucking insane this guy was.
I'm watching this diet and how they got
crazy crazy.
Eddie fled after he started just buying
boxes.
You know how you met me years ago,
you would be driving in New York and
there was some guy selling stereo
speakers.
Yeah.
And then you'd take them home and it was
two bricks.
Yep.
Well he did the same thing to investors.
He took boxes,
filled them up with bricks and just
stuck them in a warehouse and then he
went public.
So he got everybody to come down and
look at all his inventory and all these
fact checkers.
They're checking boxes as a bricks and
whoa.
And he had five fucking warehouses all
around.
They will all fake and he got all this
money.
He fled to Israel and he fled for a
while,
but they knew he was a pussy hound.
Right.
So they got them like Escobar style,
they got,
I'm like,
you know,
on the phone like I'm going to a store
or something crazy.
And what they did was they put a blonde
on the side of the road with a miniskirt
and they knew eventually he would drive
by and stopped and he stopped.
That's how they nailed them.
What is the.
Did you google the with the richest
woman in the world where they got their
money from?
He's a bad motherfucker,
paramus syosset,
Long Island.
And he had commercials.
He was the first one that pushed to
commercial barrier.
I mean I would like to look at how many
on the left
will attack others for not being
progressive enough,
not being left enough.
So I think it's a panic,
right?
You said this is the kind of behavior
you see in a panic,
a moral panic for example.
And so helen and I,
the third person who worked on the
project with us,
Helen and I wrote an essay about a year
and a half ago and talking about how the
extremism on both sides is really the
problem and most people reject it.
And should fight it.
Most of us are sensible people in the
middle who hate this.
In fact,
data just came out showing that it's 80
percent of the population,
the fringes,
both sides.
So,
and only eight percent are on the left
and 12 percent are on the right of the
fringe.
However that works out.
And so we wrote this thing and we said
that what's going on?
Actually we called it an existential
polarization.
So you have this idea that everything's
an existential crisis.
So the far right,
we'll start with them,
sees that if the Democrats get power,
oh,
it's open borders.
The terrorists are coming in.
Our entire way of life is going to be
destroyed.
Catastrophe,
catastrophe,
Ono,
Judith Butler's,
you mean 95 genders?
Quick Stop the Democrats no matter what.
And then you have the left.
Oh my God,
if they get power that everything's
gonna,
be racist.
We're going to be beating gays in the
snow.
It's going to just be the worst thing.
And that's actually kind of a joke,
but,
but it's,
it's for real though,
that they think that the world is going
to fall apart.
If the other side gets power,
and so when you have that kind of a
situation,
you have a panic and you see the
slightest bit of advantage happening on
the other side is just something to
completely freak out about.
And then what do you do?
You say,
oh well the only possible recipe to
balance the scales to turn further our
way.
If we go toward the middle,
that puts the balance.
Say if the right goes really far right,
and we on the left,
moved toward the middle.
Now the whole balance is moved,
right?
So the only way to keep the balance
close to the middle is if they go right,
we go left,
right?
Right.
So then that's going to keep the
balance.
But what that actually does is it.
This is going to get nerdy.
Hang on.
That actually puts all of the weight on
the outsides and you think about a
spinning thing,
right?
It's got centrifical forces happening.
What's that trying to do is going to rip
the spinning thing apart?
Well,
if you have all the weight crammed in
the middle,
it's like wheel.
It doesn't come apart right now.
Imagine if you had like two billiard
balls and you have like this big long
stick and there's two holes for the
builder bars.
They don't go in it like locked in
there,
just sitting there.
You spend that.
What's going to happen there?
Fly Right off,
right?
So if you have all the weight on the
outside and you start spinning a thing.
So that's like the political
conversations.
That dynamic is going to rip the thing
apart.
The more weight gets to the outside.
So one side go into the fringe doesn't
mean the other side should go to the
fringe.
That's how you a nation apart.
And uh,
I,
I pass out to 30 hits,
2:30 in the morning hits and I'm just,
I'm just,
I wake up because I hear the alarm,
you know,
kind of pop off at the,
at the hotel.
So now I'm hearing these alarms starting
to go off and I've,
you know,
I checked out,
I checked out on front,
I checked out through the window and I
check the lobby.
Nobody was moving.
So I was like,
it's a false alarm.
So I got the pillow put over my head and
every can slept through the alarm and
that happened about 2:30.
Now 4:30 comes about on this time.
I don't wake up,
I don't wake up because of the alarm.
I wake up because of the smoke.
I'm like coughing on my.
I'm like coughing on the smug.
And at first I thought I was dreaming.
So I wake up and I,
at that time I had,
I had uh,
I slept in my town.
I taught tired,
I was and I got up and then we'll go to
turn the lights and the lights turning
on and then I go through the window and
check the window.
And next,
you know what?
I see the car right in front of me on
fire.
Uh,
three fourths of the hotels,
like I was probably about five rooms
away from getting hit hard.
Like I'm talking about like,
like fire coming out the window like
that.
And I'm waking up to this,
like thinking I'm dreaming,
you know,
in a towel.
And then the lights,
everything was dark,
but I could see everything,
like the room started getting hot and I
couldn't,
I couldn't hold my breath.
The more I started looking for my shoes,
I couldn't find my shoes and I,
I bumped into my slacks that I let them
on the ironing board that the night
before and I put them on and I grabbed,
I grabbed the,
I grabbed my phone and I jumped out the
window.
I just thought the one that jumped out
the window,
my right foot catches on fire.
My right foot catches on fire fast and
I'm looking at kind of,
I'm,
I'm Kinda,
you know,
trying to put it out and it's crazy how
I can see how people could catch on fire
real quick because my right leg was,
it was,
it was crazy.
Wow.
So I jumped out and I started walking as
I'm walking them,
seeing like this,
the hotel in front of us was all in
sticks to like the whole thing was just
in sticks,
like the fire had just ate that thing
up.
There's a building in front of me on
fire.
Like I'm just walking through the
streets going up the hill and just
thinking like God can be a horrible way
to die,
horrible way to die.
And I got to,
I got a bird's eye view windows on top
of the,
uh,
when I was on top of the hill and then I
saw there's a cop down there,
there's a cop down in the middle of the
freeway just like,
you know,
that's,
that's where I got to go.
So now I'm running fast and I've seen as
this brush fire kind of come along and
just I'm seeing like California,
like just catch on fire,
like completely.
Like through my eyes had jumped over the
fence to get to the freeway,
you know,
no problem.
I'll jump over the second fence.
And then the third fence,
it was a,
it was a very,
like a flimsy,
a kind of fence and never brad as I,
as I jumped out and read snag,
like part of my snacks to keep in mind I
was,
I had the only thing I had on with
slacks,
I was commando slacks,
no shirt,
no shoes,
like out in the cold in California.
And as I that flimsy fence as,
as I jumped out that last fence at like
cut it like a part of the fence.
I grabbed my butt and it just,
it cut me open heart and a tour like
half the lake.
So now I'm full.
I'm full of smoke on my right foot's
burn.
And uh,
I'm,
I'm pretty much half naked in the middle
of the freeway.
So I see the cop car and I go up to the
cop car and as I'm going up to it,
I'm sorry,
the freaking cop car leaves,
like I can just scrambles.
I'm just like,
oh my God.
As soon as that cop car left a,
I remember seeing this big as diesel,
like coming towards me and never get
into the middle of the freeway and
Kinda,
you know,
waving my hands like,
you gotta take me,
I die like this,
like hit me dude.
And as it got closer,
so it was a fire truck and I,
and I get rescued.
I get rescued by the fireman.
They put me in their fire chicken.
They're just kinda like looking at him.
He's like down,
do you just,
you just survived death.
Oh this is it.
This is the video sent to me on that.
Oh,
here it is on Worldstar.
He kept some with the leg kick.
The guy gets up now watch this.
Watch this.
Boom.
Strong leg.
Perfectly timed.
Watch this.
Ah,
out.
Go from the beginning though.
In the beginning you see long.
It's two minutes long.
Yeah.
But the beginning,
you see how the fight starts to this
guy,
the guys a come on motherfucker,
you want some of this?
Get a shirt off.
And the guys like trying,
he's by himself and he's like,
no,
we'll do one on one.
One on one,
one on one.
You fought another dude first diddy?
Yeah.
This guy,
this guy,
this is the guy legs kicks.
And after he laid kicks,
this dude,
the other guy says,
come on,
keep it over here.
Who doesn't have a wife beater on Kimmy?
Some volume on this.
What's going to be taken down?
Rondo isn't going to get taken down from
youtube.
Oh,
okay,
okay to you.
Turn it down.
So the guy's like,
come on man.
So like one dude by himself with a bunch
of other dudes,
but he steps in.
This guy knows how to fight.
Look at it as throwing a jab and the
watch this leg kick your dog.
Oh.
So there's quite a bit first whole
different guy.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
but that's it right there.
Leg kick,
boom.
And he cracks them.
And so then the guy's like realizing
he's in trouble.
And so he starts backing away and the
guys coming forward,
he's like,
come on bitch.
And so then the other guy afterwards
goes,
oh,
you think you're to load,
kick in the leg kick.
So he comes back,
he's like,
tired of this dude walking away from him
and he's like,
I fucked this dude up with one punch and
he wants it back up and this and this
guy goes,
you want to kick,
you want Luke kick here right here.
Cool.
You don't want
to kick him.
But
he's like,
I'm going to try you.
Let's take a drag of a cigarette first
and then takes his shirt off.
Guy has no idea how to fight,
which is Hilaire fat.
Not In shape,
uhm,
like kick guys.
But people are so ridiculous with this
idea that they think they know how to
fight.
Yeah,
Bang out cold.
But that's dark man.
The banging the head,
the back of the head off the concrete is
dark.